>> Laura: THE GEORGIA
GUBERNATORIAL RACE HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE MOST HOTLY CONTESTED
RACES THIS CYCLE.
THE RACE HAS BEEN ROCKED WITH
CHARGES OF RACISM AND VOTER
SUPPRESSION WITH CELEBRITY AND
POLITICAL POWER PLAYERS
DEFENDING THROUGHOUT THE PEACH
STATE THROUGHOUT.
JOINING ME TO REACT IN THE
GEORGIA OF STATE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE BRIAN KEMP.
THANKS FOR JOINING ME TONIGHT.
THIS IS HOW STACY ABRAMS
RESPONDED TO YOUR CAMPAIGN
CHARGES OF HACKING.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I THINK HE COOKED UP THE
CHARGE BECAUSE HE REALIZES ONCE
AGAIN HE HAS LEFT 6 MILLION
VOTER INFORMATION VULNERABLE AND
HE REALIZES IF HE GOT CAUGHT TWO
DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION HAVING
EXPOSED SO MANY GEORGIANS HE
WOULD LOSE SO HE DID WHAT HE
DOES ALWAYS, BLAME SOMEONE ELSE
FOR HIS MISTAKES.
>> Laura: YOUR RESPONSE?
>> LOOK, WE GOT THIS INFORMATION
OVER THE WEEKEND IMMEDIATELY
CALLED HOMELAND SECURITY, FBI,
THE GEORGIA BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION AFTER MEETING
EARLIER TODAY, THE GEORGIA
BREWER INVESTIGATION HAS OPEN A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO THIS
MATTER.
CYBER CRIME CENTER WILL
INVESTIGATING THAT.
IT'S NOT IN THE HANDS OF MY
OFFICE CAN WE PASS INFORMATION
ALONG TO THEM.
THEY BELIEVE IT TO BE CREDIBLE
ENOUGH TO OPEN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AND THAT'S WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: CAN YOU GIVE US ANY
MORE THOUGH?
IS THERE ONE PERSON, TWO PERSON,
FIVE PEOPLE?
OVERSEAS?
IN THE COUNTRY?
>> LAURA, I UNDERSTAND.
LAURA DON'T MAKE VERY SERIOUS
MATTER, WE'VE HANDLED THIS LIKE
WE ALWAYS DO, CYBER INCIDENTS.
WHEN IT'S CRIMINAL, WE GO TO THE
PROPER AUTHORITIES.
WE'VE DONE THAT WITH THE GBI.
THEY FOUND IT TO BE CREDIBLE
ENOUGH TO OPEN THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
I WOULD DEFER QUESTIONS TO THEM
AT THIS POINT.
>> Laura: MR. SECRETARY,
PEOPLE FROM JIMMY CARTER TO, OF
COURSE, OTHER SUPPORTERS OF
STACY ABRAMS HAVE SAID, WELL,
YOU CAN'T BE IMPARTIAL DEALING
WITH ANY CLAIMS OF VOTER
SUPPRESSION OR CHALLENGES TO THE
FINAL VOTE ONCE THEY ARE ALL
CAST TOMORROW.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT HAVE BEEN,
WELCOME A BIPARTISAN COMMISSION
IS INVOLVED, LOOKING AT ANY SUCH
CHARGES, THERE ARE NO WORRIES.
DO YOU SEE WHY DEMOCRATS WOULD
BE CONCERNED AND IF THAT SHE WAS
ON THE OTHER FOOT, WOULDN'T
REPUBLICANS BE SAYING KIND OF
THE SAME THING?
>> ANYBODY KNOWS HOW THE SYSTEM
WORKS IN GEORGIA WOULDN'T BE
SAYING THAT.
THAT'S A RIDICULOUS CLAIM.
IT'S OUR COUNTY ELECTION OFFICES
AND SUPERINTENDENTS THAT
ACTUALLY HOLD THE ELECTION.
THEY ARE COUNTING THE VOTES.
LOCAL ELECTION BOARD CERTIFIES
THE ELECTIONS.
THE PRESS AND THE PUBLIC CAN GO
WATCH THAT.
ALL THIS NONSENSE OF VOTER
SUPPRESSION IS ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS.
MINORITY PARTICIPATION IS UP 23%
IN THE GREAT STATE OF GEORGIA.
THERE IS A MILLION MORE PEOPLE
ON OUR VOTER ROLLS NOW THAN WHEN
I TOOK OFFICE.
I CREATED AN ONLINE SYSTEM WHEN
GEORGIANS CAN REGISTER TO VOTE
24 HOURS A DAY, SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK.
STACY ABRAMS VOTED AGAINST THAT
LEGISLATION.
IF YOU LOOK BACK, EVERY TWO
YEARS, THE SAME THINGS, THE SAME
TYPE OF CHARGES HAVE HAPPENED
FROM HER LOCAL GROUPS THAT ARE
SUPPORTING HER EXTREME AGENDA --
SHE'S TRYING TO DISTRACT FROM
THE RECORD THAT SHE WANTS PEOPLE
WHO ARE HERE ILLEGALLY TO VOTE
FOR HER AND BE PART OF THE BLUE
WAVE.
THEY EVEN SUED US OVER THAT.
WHEN WE CALLED THEM UP AND HOW
RIDICULOUS THAT WAS, THEY
WITHDREW THE COMPLAINT AND THEY
WERE SUING US TO DO SOMETHING
THAT WE ALREADY DO.
THIS IS THE 11TH HOUR TACTICS OF
THEM.
I'M DOING MY JOB, LORI
LAURA.
I'M DOING MY JOB TO KEEP
ELECTION SECURE, ACCESSIBLE,
FAIR.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE DOING.
>> Laura: MR. OBAMA COMES INTO
TOWN, MR. SECRETARY, OPRAH COMES
AT THE TOWN.
IT WAS ALL STAR POWER ALL THE
TIME.
THEY COME IN, THEY CAN DRAW A
HUGE CROWD.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THE STAR
POWER WILL TRANSLATE INTO VOTES
AND PEOPLE JUST SAY, WELL, I
LIKE PRESIDENT OBAMA.
GREAT PERSON, WE LIKE THEM AS
PRESIDENT.
OPRAH CAN WE REALLY LOVE HER
SHOW.
WE LOVE HER MAGAZINE.
WE ARE GOING TO TURN OUT AND
VOTE FOR ABRAMS, TWO HISTORIC
AFRICAN-AMERICAN SUCCESS STORIES
OR URGING PEOPLE TO MAKE HISTORY
ONCE AGAIN IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA EXPECT >>
PRESIDENT OBAMA DIDN'T WIN
GEORGIA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP THINKS HIGHLY OF
OPRAH WINFREY.
BUT GEORGIA IS GOING TO VOTE FOR
THE BEST PERSON TO MOVE THEIR
STEP FORWARD.
I TALKED ABOUT THAT LAST NIGHT,
THEY HAD THE SUPPORT OF THERE'S
THE CELEBRITIES.
A LOT OF OTHER GREAT GEORGIANS,
I THINK THAT'S WHAT GEORGIANS
WANT.
THEY WANT A GOVERNOR THAT'S
GOING TO BUILD OFF OF US BEING
THE NUMBER ONE STATE FOR
BUSINESS IN THE COUNTRY SIX
YEARS IN A ROW, THAT WAS
ANNOUNCED TODAY BY
GOVERNOR DEAL.
I'M GLAD TO HAVE THE SUPPORT AS
WELL AS FORMER GOVERNOR SONNY
PURDUE.
IF WE HAD A GREAT ONE OF
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP OVER THE
LAST 16 YEARS.
I WANT TO KEEP THAT SAME
DIRECTION AND MOVE IT TO A NEW
LEVEL.
STACY ABRAMS WANTS TO TAKE THAT
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT, RAISING
TAXES, HAVING BIGGER GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT --
>> Laura: GEORGIA'S ECONOMIC
REVIVAL HAS BEEN SOMETHING TO
WATCH.
PEOPLE WANTING TO TURN THAT BACK
AND SAY NO BECAUSE OPRAH CAME
INTO TOWN?
GOD BLESS HER, BUT YOU CAN'T
ARGUE WITH SUCCESS.
MR. SECRETARY, WE'LL BE WATCHING